bonjour aujourd'hui on va parler des
vikings c'est parti c'est ça ton info tu
crois qu'en des vikings faisait un rêve
quelque part il commençait par bonjour
aujourd'hui on va appuyer vos biens
partis l'union vous pète la gueule non
on est des guerriers génériques
dans cet épisode nous allons présenter
les principaux traits de la société
vikings en insistant sur quelques idées
reçues qu'il convient d'éradiquer quand
on parle de vikings on désigne en fait
un type particulier de scandinavie
il s'agit d'un billard ou guerrier
d'origine scandinave entre le 8e et le
xième siècle soit la période où ils font
le plus parler d'eux on ne peut donc pas
désigné comme vikings l'ensemble de la
population scandinaves et on leur a
aussi donné des noms différents selon
les peuples comme les francs qui les ont
appelés les normands où l'esclave qui
les ont appelés les vars et pour les
scandinaves de l'époque un viking c'est
quelqu'un qui part en expédition ils
m'ont dit que je n'étais qu'un
scandinave
alors je suis devenu un viking et d'où
viennent les vikings exactement nous
répondrons à cette question palpitante
grâce à une très jolie carte se trouvait
sur un moteur de recherche quelconque
tout commence au viiie siècle en norvège
suède et danemark où se trouvent les
populations scandinaves qui nous
intéresse en rouge foncé sur la carte
pour des raisons que nous détaillerons
plus tard ces scandinaves décide d'aller
conquérir des terres un peu partout en
rouge orange et jaune vous pouvez
observer les différents territoires où
les scandinaves se sont établies du 9e
au 11e siècle on retient surtout une
partie de l'angleterre l'islande le
groenland est un grand territoire en
russie où sa femme les vagues les
territoires en verre ne sont pas des
territoires où les vikings s'installe
mais où il effectué des raids
durant toute cette période de pillage
intense au délà de ses conquêtes et
pillages la société scandinave était
organisée sous la forme de clan dirigé
par regarde en haut du yart bas de plus
les ja sont élus notamment pour leurs
capacités de chef de guerre ils sont à
la tête d'un clan à égalité avec les
autres clans alentours mais n'ont pas
autant pouvoir coréen droit européen la
société scandinave étant beaucoup plus
libertaire ils sont également soumis aux
lois qui existait déjà avant le en
dessous des gars se trouvaient les bois
être c'est à dire tous les hommes libres
qui disposait du droit de vote
en gros sous sont les citoyens il existe
des différences entre eux mais ils
forment le gros de la population
scandinave dans cette société les femmes
ont un rang inférieur à celui de
en matière politique et juridique mais
elles ont aussi des responsabilités dans
la maison et lorsque les hommes partent
en mer ce qui leur confère une certaine
autorité
enfin la caste des trajets des composés
des esclaves capturé dans des raids qui
n'étaient pas libres et ne pouvaient pas
voter
mais il avait une certaine liberté et
couvet s'affranchir très facilement on
est loin de ce que le mot esclave et 20
qu'habituellement
la société est donc divisée en trois
ordres c'est vachement original c'était
plus compliqué que ça il avait aussi des
égaux dit qu'on peut associer maman en
prêtre les esclaves affranchis qui sont
encore à part mais pour faire ça qu'il y
avait des gars les bois hêtre et les
esclaves ok ok c'est de première
catégorie se réunissent et l'ordi thing
une assemblée saisonnière se donnant
généralement au printemps en juin et en
automne et durant laquelle les hommes
libres du clan débattent et décider des
lois et rendait la justice qu'on lui
coupe la peine de mort n'était pas
appliquée enfin entre qu'on le bat nice
nous allons maintenant nous intéresser
aux invasions à proprement parler la
première cause est assez évidente
outre la soif de richesse et de gloire
d'autres causes sont invoqués comme le
fait que les premiers vikings auraient
pu être des révoltés au banik arte voir
ailleurs aucune rivalité entre les clans
et pousser les moins fortunés a essayé
d'aller s'enrichir c'est qui le lui ont
maintenant d'autres avancent encore
l'idée que céret des invasions soit une
réaction aux tentatives de conversion
des chrétiens et enfin dernier argument
c'est trop facile
ils sont tellement mauvais ce serait un
crime de se priver c'est ainsi que les
vikings commence par pie ix et des
monastères cuit à s'imposer de plus en
plus on leur file des tribus piliers
terre pour essayer les calmer dans cette
partie nous reviendrons sur certains
clichés tenaces par rapport au combat
vikings les bateaux d'abord joue
grandement dans la supériorité technique
des vikings sachez qu'à aucun moment on
ne parle de drakkars les termes
apparaissant au 19e siècle les vikings
qualifier dès ce qu'est leur bateau de
guerre et de manière plus générale les
badauds sont des flancs nord jada sont
des bateaux qui peuvent transporter
jusqu'à 70 personnes et qui peuvent
naviguer un peu partout grâce à leur
tirant d'eau très faible aucune rivière
de leur résiste exemplaires le mieux
conservé le bateau d'oseberg
voyez ici pour se battre les vikings
était vêtue simplement afin de s'assurer
une grande liberté de mouvement elle
cote de maille ont été retrouvées mais
elles semblent rares et des probablement
réservé à l'élite pour ce défense vous
avez leurs boucliers
passons aux armes maintenant je suis
prête il pouvait être équipés de hache
mais c'était plutôt des diagrammes de g
leurs principales armes étant l'épée
long et ouais et bien sûr ne pouvons pas
oublier
vous le sentez ce silence ce sont tous
les participants au banquet du valhalla
qui viennent de stopper leur festin pour
nous juger
moi et mon casque à cornes avec dédain
la légende remonte à des casques
retrouvait au danemark qui ont été
attribuées à tort aux vikings
ils ont été attribués à d'orgue aux
vikings il s'agissait en réalité de
casques 7 probablement cérémonielles et
qu'il avait donc d'avant les bugs liqing
parmi tous les casques vikings ont
trouvé on en trouvait aucun comportant
des cordes et les seules représentations
de viking avec des cornes trouver sur
des gravures et est donc probablement
des représentations imagées les vikings
porter des casques en cuir bouilli ou en
métal sans tous ces ornements qui
n'auraient pas été pratique pour se
battre je te sent tendu harold au 19e
siècle la mythologie nordique inspire de
nombreux artistes dans les domaines de
la musique la peinture et c'est à partir
de cette époque qu'on commence à voir
des représentations de viking avec des
casques à cornes
ils sont ensuite reprises dans astérix
au cinéma et qui sont encore tenaces
deux jours forte heureusement des
productions récentes c'est peut-être que
la série vikings laisse tomber ce cliché
merci rac d'arles aux banques et ce
casque là il est historique pas repose
le casque de l'eau qui tout de suite
sacrilège
je passerai rapidement sur cette partie
parce qu'elle mériterait une vidéo à
part entière ou sans aux mille et
scandinave était politique
un groupe de dieu composé principalement
des vannes et dieu de la fertilité et
des états la bulgarie et puissant ces
croyances reposer sur 8 aux logiques
complexe coexistence dollar remonte
hydrazine ou de différents moyens comme
la terre et dans le royaume de mickey
ward le fait que les vikings soit payen
a pu jouer dans la vision de barbares
sanguinaires caen avait les peuples
chrétiens
malheureusement les principaux textes
qui nous raconte la mythologie nordique
et nous conservons ont été écrits par
des chrétiens c'est notamment le cas de
l'état de se nourrit écrite au xiiie
siècle et qui est l'une des principales
sources sur la mythologie nordique
il est probable que l'auteur et
réinventer cette mythologie en y
ajoutant son influence chrétienne ce qui
rend la mythologie nordique ancien plus
difficile à saisir
à la fin du 10ème siècle les scandinaves
se convertissent au christianisme et
c'est l'une des principales causes de la
fin de la période vikings j'espère que
cet épisode vous a plu et je vous
remercie d'avoir été très nombreux à
regarder des vidéos et à vous abonner
depuis le mois de septembre pour cette
fois j'ai traité d'un sujet qui m'avait
été suggérée mais qui me plaît
énormément
si vous voulez en savoir plus régis
boyer est l'un des principaux auteurs
sur les vikings je me suis des deux sont
en vie
pour les vikings pour préparer cette
vidéo merci d'avoir regardé et à la
prochaine